Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's a Monday morning podcast for Monday,
may the sixth,
may the sixth.
Did you read,
did you read your forecast for the day?
What does it say?
What is that shit called?
Astrology.
Why don't we look up old fucking astrology right now?
You know what?
It's raining out here in Los Angeles.
Everybody always freaks out.
Oh my God,
it's Ray.
I can't drive it.
This stuff.
Um Oh,
here's the astrology and who we have on his star of the day.
Who Will it be?
George Clooney.
Abbott.
Dentally.
He's a tourist and he was born today,
May 6th,
1961 happy birthday to George Clooney.
Who turns 52 today.
Um,
what kind of an asshole?
I'll tell you what kind of an asshole looks this shit up.
Adolf Hitler and thank God he did.
Maybe if he didn't have his head up in the stats,
the white at one that fucking war.
Right?
And I'll tell you right now,
most of us wouldn't be here,
including myself.
Do you think dead beady little shark?
I'd fucking
Amy Schumer Cheek Psycho would fucking put up with my red edit face walking
around.
I don't think he would.
I think he'd look at me and go now.
Oh Shit.
Um,
I drank like a fucking idiot late yesterday.
I was going so well.
Everybody,
when I was fighting that demon,
that little whore,
that little harlot that I like to call alcoholism,
I was doing so great by great.
What I meant was I was actually working out in the morning before I went out and
got shit faced.
That's how I fucking wrestle that demon to the ground high.
You're like,
got shit.
Huh?
Empty calories.
Of course you have to
tap out.
Tap Out.
Um,
no.
I've been doing great.
I've been doing this stairs.
This is set of stairs down the fucking street.
And I know what most people see.
Most people drive by.
They see a set of stairs,
but not all freckle face here.
You know what I see,
I see a free gym.
So I had been going up and down these fucking things.
All right,
well there's,
there's four sets of stairs and I'm doing them with the Cleveland Zone,
Jason Law head.
All right,
there's four sets of stairs.
So we're looking at it like a basketball game.
All right?
The first set of stairs is the first quarter,
second stairs,
second quarter.
You get the idea,
right?
Something to take our mind off.
The fact that we're a couple of booze hound is trying to drag a fucking drunk
ass is hung over ass is up the stairs.
So you basically,
you go up,
down,
up,
that's the first quarter.
Then the second quarter is a short one.
So that one you got to run,
you're trying to run him out of the building or if you walk at that,
uh,
you know,
you blew a fucking eight point lead right up,
down,
up,
and then we fucking,
uh,
the last two a brutal up,
down,
up and down,
up,
down,
and then you walk all the way around,
you loop around,
and then you've got the last two.
When you go up,
down,
up,
and that's fucking overtime and you basically want to kill yourself afterwards.
But I've got to tell you something,
you know,
if you do that shit and you come home and you resist the urge to get a breakfast
burrito or whatever the fuck it is you do and your neck of the woods,
if you just have a few,
if you just sit there and you force yourself to eat,
like you're in a prison camp,
the weight will come off.
Um,
why am I talking about this shit?
Yeah,
I'm back to having my banana for breakfast.
Although if I do that fucking workout,
I do a,
I'll have the oatmeal and a banana.
That's what I do.
If you guys were ever wondering what my beauty secrets are,
if you ever wondered how it is that I keep the glow,
how I keep the light in my eye,
when I walk into a room,
everybody just goes,
wow,
who is that gentleman and what are his ideas that I can invest in?
Um,
that's what it is right there.
Up,
down,
up on the fucking stairs,
a bowl of oatmeal with nothing else in it.
Maybe a couple of bananas,
slices of Banana.
And that's it.
You eat like you're in some bamboo cage,
treading water with a couple of rats.
All right?
That's what you have to do.
And your fucking forties if you don't want to end up with one of those Sammy
Hagar Torsos you know we just still trying to wear the t shirt and you look okay
straight on,
as long as it's black.
But when you turned to the side,
he just got all that extra fucking meat,
you know,
you gotta be able to put your hand down.
It'd be able to get your thumb to the back and your fingers to the front.
All right?
When your whole hand can just be on the side.
You got,
you got,
you got to shave down that ham.
All right?
So anyways,
that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to shave it down.
I was at my fight and fuck your weight and like an asshole.
They put on like 13 pounds being a fucking Goddamn waffle.
Leeton fucking moron.
So now look what I have to do.
I gotta eat like a fucking God.
Like I mean,
oh God damn a pow camp.
Why do I do that to myself?
How many fucking times,
Bill,
are you going to get down to your way and be like,
oh,
that's great.
You know what?
It's celebration.
I'm going to have a cheeseburger and some ice cream and go right back to the tub
of fucking Shit I was before.
I'm sick of it.
I hate myself.
I'm sick of that cycle.
Um,
whatever.
So it's raining out here,
which is great because the hills are on fire.
The hills are on fire out here,
which are actually a phenomenal part of nature out here.
Um,
if human beings weren't living in the hills,
it would be great.
We could all just sit back and sort of enjoy nature doing what it does.
Hills catch on fire.
I've,
I've gone through this before,
right?
Basically,
this is how the weather works out here.
Um,
it rains,
you used to be January and February now like fucking rains in December.
It's like earlier,
you know,
and fuck all you people in Minnesota okay with you.
Oh my God,
it's snowing in May.
Why are you acting like you didn't just put away your mittens?
Okay.
You live in Minnesota,
you know what you signed up for?
What'd you think you were going to be doing in May?
Waterski oh,
it would have been nice.
Um,
46 fucking inches.
And everybody's out there acting like,
you know,
they're acting like it's snowing in May.
I wish I could have put on Fox News.
I know they were like global warming.
Huh?
Um,
fuck the polar ice caps melting.
It's snowing in Minnesota in May.
Let's see what the liberals have to say about this.
Is that a polar bear?
Um,
so anyways,
the fucking hills were on fire.
We drove,
we drove out to a,
we drove,
me and La had did a Chumash casino.
Somebody told me Chumash means number five in a native American.
I have no idea.
I don't know if it's the name of their tribe.
You know,
if they still on the hills out here when they were on fire and yelled at the
Apaches,
you know,
Chumash mother fuckers.
I don't know if they said that.
I have no idea.
Well if they just put five fingers in the air and that meant to gather up,
gather up,
we're going to go get some squat pussy tonight.
I have no idea what it meant,
but all I know is I went out there and I had a great fucking time,
but we're driving out there and I know you Californians are used to this shit,
but we're just driving out there and all of a sudden you just come over the hill
on the highway and you look in the distance and there's an entire hill that is
just completely can't say completely engulfed in flames.
It's just walls of fire working its way up the hill.
And um,
you just sort of drive by it taking video,
not paying attention to where you're going.
Like I did.
I'll try and send you some of the video.
Um,
gle,
you're really going to try,
how are you going to try what?
Fucking select it and hit send.
I'm going to send the video.
I'll have the video.
Okay.
Anyways,
um,
and I actually went home the next day and I was watching these firefighters on
the fucking news.
If you get a chance,
go on youtube.
Maybe there's some clips out there watching these guys fight the fires.
It's,
it's unbelievable.
First of all,
it's like 85 fucking degrees out without the hill being on fire and like seven
of them walk up this hill.
Here I am bragging about doing these stairs up,
down,
up,
down.
These guys have like a fucking,
you know,
60,
70 pounds worth of equipment,
that heavy rain coat and they'd just walk it up this hill.
Like it's nothing.
They get up there.
I noticed one guy's got the red helmet.
He's leading the way.
So evidently he's the fucking chief.
So they're standing right next to this wall of fire and he just Kinda,
yeah,
it,
it's so bad at that,
that,
and then these fucking guys.
Yeah.
They,
they just get after it to guys of the giant fucking chain saws.
They start cutting away the brush.
The other guys are grabbing the brush,
thrown it in the opposite direction.
Okay.
Of the fire.
Next thing you know there's a trail and they've established a perimeter,
you know,
and the fire is like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck happened?
I thought everything was all good.
And they said,
I don't think so.
Fire.
Why don't you just sit there and either go in the other direction over shit.
You already burned out or just sadly fucking fade away like a child star.
That's exactly what they did.
I watched him save people's houses.
They're unbelievable.
When it was in that moment that I realized I could never be a firefighter,
I don't have what it takes.
Yeah.
I don't,
I have the wrong pigment to be walking up that fucking hill with all of that
shit on.
You know,
I was joking that night in the comedy club that if I worked in a firehouse I'd
be that guy who stay hangs back and like makes the Chili,
you know,
everybody calling me a pussy.
Some homophobic words,
you know there would be,
yeah,
there'll be nothing against gay people.
It would just all about making me feel like a fucking chili making pussy.
I'd be sitting there stir in the pot ape.
Be careful out there guys.
I heard it's a hot one.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck fucking goddamn broad.
Make me some fucking dude.
His fish
and I'd sit there with my big firemen,
red mustache,
little tear in my eye.
Sitting there all alone.
Taste in my chili.
It's a pepper Rico.
Oh God.
Do you guys realize not one nail has been put into my house since they demoed it
the other day or whatever fucking was at six weeks ago.
We're still fighting with these insurance cuts over to grant cause I know what
that they can.
It's to grant.
This guy eventually is going to get sick of fucking looking at this mess.
And you know what?
They don't know.
They don't know what they're dealing with it.
They don't know how stubborn I am.
I'm going the opposite direction.
What I'm really seeing is all my shit that I had in the walk in closet,
you know,
just strewn about in this room downstairs.
And I'm just looking at all of it.
Go on.
What the fuck do I need this stuff for?
What is that?
Do you know how it came across the other day?
Do you remember when those Mitchell and ness throwback jerseys were?
All the fucking rage.
Remember that?
I remember the late great Patrice O'Neal.
Please download his CD.
Mr P,
all the proceeds go to his,
uh,
his wife and his mom.
Um,
he,
I think at one point his entire wardrobe
okay.
Consisted of those fucking jerseys.
Okay.
You know,
and we used to give him shit when he come in wearing a fucking wide receivers.
Jersey Sandy was too big.
He should only buy throwback Lyman jerseys.
Um,
and he's like,
yeah.
And then of course he'd fucking trashed the shit out of us,
but whatever.
So during that time they had a Fran Tarkenton throwback jersey.
The,
uh,
the white one.
Lsu,
by the way,
I dunno who ripped off who probably the vikings ripped off Lsu considering,
uh,
Lsu has been around forever,
but um,
I have a fucking Fran Tarkenton Throwback Jersey and I'm like,
I forgot I even had that.
And then I remembered why I never wore it because I got it and I put it on and I
look like an asshole.
Okay.
I don't know what it was about the colors.
I don't know if it was the numbers.
I don't know if it was my dumb fucking face,
but I literally,
the second I put it on,
I looked like I had a fatal disease and I was waiting for Fran Tarkington to
show up next to my hospital bed.
That's what I look like.
So I never fucking war.
I bought this fucking thing,
you know?
Remember those things.
They were like 200 bucks to 50.
I've never worn that fucking thing.
All right.
And if you can send me an email,
if you're almost five foot 10 like I am in roughly way about a buck 72 a buck 80
depending on how much you booze.
And if you can send me a fucking email as to why you're a giant Fran Tarkenton
fan and all that bullshit,
you leave your address,
I'll mail that fucker til you.
Cause you know what?
I'm done with all of this shit.
Fucking drop my computer,
you asshole.
I'm done with all of this shit.
All right.
I'm not going to be the guy with a bunch of shit,
you know that gradually ends up my garage and plastic tins like this fucking
shit.
I'm not doing it.
I'm getting rid of all of my stuff.
Okay?
All these fucking books I already read and they still have them.
I'm getting rid of all of them.
You know,
when I was actually thinking this is a,
this would be a fucking hilarious way.
Two and a very sneaky way.
Gradually get out of a relationship that you want to be in.
You know,
possibly the biggest,
you know,
pussy way out of relationship rather than it just sitting down.
And what I've always told you guys to do it,
you just sit down with the person.
He just say,
listen,
we need to talk.
You sit down and you just started off with I'm not happy.
And that's the thing.
Well what if I did this,
that and that.
I'm just not happy.
What is it?
Is it the sex?
I'm just not happy.
Whatever man or woman.
All right,
so say you didn't want to have that conversation.
Say it just gives you so many deuce chose.
What if,
well it did was without her knowing,
just ever so subtly over the course of eight excruciating months still in that
relationship you didn't want to be.
And what if he just gradually kind of got rid of all of your shit,
you know?
And the way you cover for it is you do yoga every day.
So he just tell you know your significant other,
that it's just a spiritual,
new spiritual path that you're taking.
And there'll be psyched in one way because I was getting rid of all of this
shit.
That's fucking great.
There's more room for my stuff.
Right,
and then when you're down to like a backpack worth a shit and the clothes on
your back,
you put your toothbrush in your little fanny pack,
whatever you have left and you just,
hey,
I'm going to go run some errands.
He just walk out the door and that's it.
You're out.
There's another way to do it.
People,
you know some day I'm putting the book out thousand and one ways to get out of a
fucking relationship.
That's one of them right there.
That's number 872 I just flipped through the book.
A little manuscript.
That's one for you.
All right.
Anyways,
how far into this podcast are we?
Everybody?
That was a lovely 16 minutes here.
How bout a little advertisements?
How the hell do I get to him live reads [inaudible].
Okay,
here we go.
Pro Flowers.
Hey everybody.
Guess what it is next Sunday.
You know what is it's mother's Day.
Who's more important than your mom?
Nobody.
Unless she didn't stick around,
you know?
Then I would just wait until father's day and get the flowers for your dad.
Thought as he can handle it all as he won't slap in the face with them.
Go.
And what are you giving me flowers for?
What are you trying to say about me?
You think I'm like that guy,
that basketball player.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
Mother's Day is this Sunday.
Okay,
here's the angle we have this week.
Proflowers everybody sibling rivalry does doesn't end because you moved out of
the house.
You can still one up him.
Your brother sends a card,
your sister remembers to call.
Guess what you do.
You taught both of them and send flowers to your mom on mother's Day.
It's brilliant.
I got to do is just call up the number,
big bang.
Boom.
You can do it right from your kick,
from your cubicle.
Here's the offer.
Pro Flowers has a hundred blooms for mom for just 1999.
That's 50% off everybody for just $10 more.
And you're going to tell me your mom's not worth $10 more.
You're really going to sit there and look me and my computer screen right in the
face and tell me she's not worth $10 more.
10 bucks more.
You upgrade to 100 blooms with premium,
with a premium pink vase and chocolates.
You just need my code.
Burb Bu Rr when you order to get these special prices,
um,
a hundred blooms for mom is a huge,
uh,
is a huge bouquet or a bow cay.
Wherever the hell you say it.
Basically,
you're doing more than a card.
You're going to one up all your friends,
family,
and everybody else.
Go to proflowers.com click on the microphone in the top right hand corner and
type in [inaudible].
That's pro flowers.com.
Click on the microphone and type in birth order mother's Day,
flowers today.
It's this Sunday.
Okay.
Stop having it in the back of your head.
Stop having a string tied around your finger.
Just do it right now and relax.
Enjoy the rest of your day.
Okay.
He voice everybody.
He voices.
The reason you're going to make more money in 2013 here,
what I just said,
if you're sitting around going,
how am I going to make more money in 2013 I have your answer.
He voice when your customers call,
you'll have your own toll free number,
professional greeting,
dial by name directory,
and more.
You'll sound like a fortune 500 company.
Even if you're living in your mom's basement and you know what that does,
it blows away your competitors.
He voice lets you give out one number that rings wherever you are,
the beach,
the bar,
doesn't matter.
You'll sound like you're at the office.
You got to go to he voice and use my Promo Code Bill.
He voice takes all your voicemails,
transcribes them and sends to you,
sends them to you instantly as you text or email.
So not only is this thing phenomenal,
if you're in business,
it's even better if you're trying to start a business while you still have
another job,
okay?
Because the person on the other end of the line is not going to know that.
And if something important happens,
you get the text message.
You know what you do?
You go run to the bathroom.
Excuse me,
everybody.
I had a,
I had Indian food last night.
You take off and you handle your business and you gradually get your own
business going.
All right,
so here's the deal.
Go to [inaudible] dot com promo code built.
That's [inaudible] dot com promo code bill,
or just go to the podcast page on billboard.com.
You Click on the voice banner right now.
That is it.
God bless you.
And God bless the United States of America.
All right,
back to the podcast,
every one.
Um,
so as always,
you know what my life is?
My life is travel,
my life is booze,
my life is sports.
That's it.
Like I was supposed to make like,
like if I was in rehab or some shit and I was supposed to make a pie about what
it is that I do,
you know,
and I swear to God,
no matter what I wrote,
I know the person would be like,
you know,
looking at this pie,
I see a lot of sadness.
It's like,
dude,
are you,
are you looking at the pie?
I travel,
I tell jokes and then I get drunk afterwards.
Where do you see the sadness in there?
It's my job to find sadness.
Oh fuck you.
All right.
Make an addiction your fucking life submission.
You don't realize I'm going to,
I'm going to give away some of these books that I have and uh,
oh,
I also didn't say,
uh,
I didn't say where to send the emails to for the Fran Jersey.
Send it to uh,
uh,
bill at [inaudible] dot com and I'll sift through those mother fuckers.
I might even send you a book with it.
Huh?
You want to read about Bob?
Prober I have is hard covered autobiography.
Um,
maybe ric flair to be the man you gotta beat the man.
I mean,
what am I supposed to die of?
Random.
I got it.
Send the fucking memory bank.
You know what sucks is one time I took a bunch of used books down the street to
this bookstore and it brought him in and this fucking content,
I think I told this story.
I bought that Anthony Kiedis one I was telling,
you know,
jumping on a plane,
I'm like,
oh,
the guy from red hot chili peppers,
the guy's a rock star.
He never has a shirt on.
How much pussy did this guy get?
I want to read about it.
Right.
So I read his book and it was,
yeah,
that was all right.
Okay.
No,
I thought it was kind of a con to flee.
Seemed like a bully.
Kind of seem like he had like a fucking,
uh,
you know,
that battered wife relationship with flea.
I love you bro.
I love you.
And then does something really mean that?
Not fully.
I'm sorry man.
I'm so come on back.
Stop being mean to me,
Anthony.
Right.
It just was really uncomfortable and parts of it,
you know,
and
maybe I was fucking super imposing that I have no idea what,
whatever.
So I bring it down there and uh,
you know,
do you realize the Douche bag behind the fucking counter?
Okay.
Kind of like did some sort of half a laugh,
like laughing that I bought this fucking book.
You know what I mean?
And it's just like,
dude,
what was I supposed to read?
The autobiography or your life?
Huh?
The sarcastic guy at the fucking used bookstore
surrounded by books.
Although your life would make a good one.
The irony of that.
How about that?
Huh?
Oh,
Jesus.
The violent thoughts that went through my head.
I didn't say anything.
I was actually embarrassed,
which happens to me a lot in life.
People just catch me off guard and they call me out for the pathetic Douche that
I am and I believe it or not,
for as much as I handle hecklers onstage when I go offstage,
I think that that's,
uh,
the microphones,
like my utility belt,
the second that's not in my hand,
I go back to being the pathetic douche that needs to go on stage to feel good
about himself.
Wow.
This is very therapeutic this week.
Puric therapeutic.
That didn't sound right.
There are patients,
um,
anyways,
did anybody watch the,
uh,
the Celtics New York Knicks series?
How fucking amazing was that?
All right.
And I called it the fucking Boston Celtics have the most hot and the Goddamn
league.
Okay.
All you fucking knick fans who are texting me.
When you were up by 20 with like eight minutes ago in the fourth quarter,
it was hilarious.
It was already coming in all the text messages na,
na,
hey,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Fucking Celtics within like one on a 20 old run,
got it down to like four points or whatever.
So maybe we were down like 25.
I don't even know.
And um,
and I love that we would,
we would down by like 20 points in the fourth quarter and none of the Celtics
fans left.
I'm sure a couple did.
But for the most part,
the place was still packed chanting,
let's go Celtics,
you know,
Laker feds,
I'm not saying this in a bad way,
but if you want to learn how to be better fans,
that's something you guys ought to do.
You know what I mean?
Now,
if we were the Lakers this year who had way more talent than the Celtics,
we would've got swept,
you know,
and one of our best guys would've fucking deliberately got as second technical
cause he doesn't want to go out there and feel the shame of being swept.
All of that stuff,
you know,
Laker fence.
Um,
I'm extending an olive branch to try and help you guys become better fans.
All right.
And is the thing if one of your players,
no matter how much you love him,
walks off on the rest of his teammates,
you bull him the next fucking game.
You don't chant MVP and him thus boosting his ego even higher to the point when
he gets an injury,
he starts tweeting during the game,
criticizing his own fucking coach.
You know,
still being a distraction,
not even on the team,
still disrupting team chemistry,
you know,
it's going to kill me is when Colby comes back from this injury.
Um,
the way that ESPN fucking drops to their knees and blows that guy,
they are going to talk about this guy like he did his own surgery.
You know,
they're never going to think,
well,
they've been working on athletes with this,
this same injury and the advancements in modern medicine are so fucking
incredible that these guys can sit here with like,
you know,
somebody's dabbing the sweat off their brow as they have.
Like,
you know,
when he called microscope glasses on or whatever to read to fucking remanned
Coby Brian so he can go back out there and probably be 90% of what he used to be
as opposed to back in the day where your career was over.
Or like Dominique Wilkins who had to take a year off,
still was comeback player of the year.
They'll never bring that up either.
Dominique Wilkins,
he won't get any love.
He won't get any love about it.
They'll act like nobody has ever done this before.
Maybe they'll bring up Jerry Rice coming back from his,
uh,
ACL.
They'll talk about that.
Maybe they'll do that and it's gonna.
It's gonna make me absolutely like projectile vomit onto my flat screen TV when
they're just like,
what does it say about this guy as desired?
I mean,
you're like,
hey,
says it himself.
All he wants to Ali wants to do is wind as he drives shack out of fucking town,
drives coaches out of town and very pale walks off the court,
every pig and say,
all right,
I'm done trashing the guy.
All right.
He could blow up both his and beat up me and everybody I know while eating the
fucking BLT.
I realize this.
All right,
but if I didn't bring this shit up,
um,
it wouldn't make me a typical country fan on the Internet.
What it,
well,
there you go.
Um,
so anyways,
all those Celtics fans who were at the game,
I just want to tell you out here,
living in Laker land,
I couldn't have been more proud of the way you guys cheered on the team and you
stuck around and he didn't fucking run out of the building.
You know,
knick fans would have stuck around,
but up top,
up top,
they would download all those other guys.
You know,
all those celebrities,
Victoria's secret models sit next to the fucking action stars.
They all would've left spike Lee with a state.
You know,
what has he been wearing lately?
You know what I mean?
He looks like he was a huge Justin Timberlake fan and he's also going to clown
college.
All right.
Anyways,
if anybody been watching any of the,
uh,
the NHL playoffs,
they've been phenomenal so far.
Of course I'm watching the Bruins may beliefs and,
uh,
can anybody explain this to me?
Because this seems to be a,
anytime there's a playoff series in,
in,
uh,
I would say in basketball and hockey to be specific,
not in baseball because baseball,
it's more about your stat and pitcher.
Um,
but the first two games of the Bruins,
maple leafs series,
okay.
Gave one,
it looked like we were going to sweep the fucking maple leafs.
It looked like,
why the fuck out of fucked did the maple leafs even make the playoffs?
Bruins flying up and down the ice?
They hitting the maple leafs.
Maple leafs aren't doing anything.
They looked like they were intimidated.
We score four goals,
bing,
Bang,
boom.
Four to one easy fucking victory gained.
Two comes around.
It's completely 100%.
The exact opposite.
Bruins are on their heels,
the fucking maple leafs of pushing us around.
We're taking it and now we look like that frustrating team that I watched all
year that can't score more than two goals.
And um,
can anybody explain to me what,
what the fuck that is?
You know what happens,
happens,
what happens in those 48 hours between the games?
I just,
I don't understand it.
So tonight the Bruins and a maple leafs,
the plan,
again,
I gotta be honest with you,
I have no idea what to expect.
No idea what to expect.
But I could tell you this.
Phil Kessel is a great player but has one of the,
I'd say top 10 most hateable faces in professional sports right now.
I don't know what that look is on his face.
I think if you have like a lot of baby fat on your face,
it makes you very hateable.
I Dunno what it is.
Maybe it's helmet
wishes,
his cheeks,
it and they kind of stick out over his nose.
I don't know what it is.
Why is my voice cracking?
Like I'm going through puberty.
I have no idea.
And I'm also of course,
paying attention to the,
uh,
Canadians Ottawa series.
I was at a,
I was at a cookout yesterday.
Cinco de Mayo,
self dumb.
I am last year.
I actually,
what day?
I said,
what day is that?
Cinco de Mayo.
Now for all you other people who didn't know a lick of Spanish like me,
that literally means May 5th
as the name of the holiday.
The name of the holiday is May 5th or the 5th of May or 5th of May.
I don't know how to fucking translate it.
Um,
but I missed the fucking game and that looks,
it looked like an old school Adam's division.
You know,
even though it was six to one total lopsided victory for,
uh,
Ottawa,
I really wished that I watched the game and I can guaran fucking tee you.
It's going to make no sense.
I,
the Canadians are going to come back just like the maple leafs I'm predicting in
the next fucking game and they're going to totally turn around and they'll
probably win six to one now.
They won't because I think Ottawa,
the goalies too fucking good.
But,
uh,
here's a question I have.
What are people going to wise up to that PK,
sue bon fucking move where he's backing up acting like he's going to give you
the zone and then he fucking does a couple of crossovers,
leaves his feet and gives you a shoulder to the face.
You know the ref standard right there.
Oh,
that's a clean hit.
It's a fucking phenomenal move.
Phenomenal move.
I don't know.
I don't understand why guys don't see it coming.
Just gotta be a reason.
Anybody.
That's it.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's read one of these,
these,
uh,
these fucking things here.
Ah,
Jesus.
Do I need to buy a new wire or something?
All of a sudden it's cutting out one headphone.
All right.
To trust or not to trust.
Um,
Oh,
before I get into that,
a condolences to that.
Uh,
the referee,
um,
who ref that soccer game,
that high school soccer game out in Colorado when the worst things I stories
ever,
he gave somebody a yellow card in this 17 year old kid,
lost his temper and turned around and punched the guy in the face.
And I dunno if it was the way he landed.
I don't know if he had preexisting stuff for this kid,
just caught them the right way.
But the guy,
the ref went into a coma for like four or five days and he passed away.
So,
uh,
it's just the,
it's still worst.
I Dunno,
I can't say it's a warm,
it's so many awful things have happened in the last fucking month or so.
But um,
oh Jesus Christ,
everybody involved on either side.
I mean,
I know as much as people are going to get mad at that kid,
17 fucking years old.
Uh,
I just can't imagine it.
You know,
you
got your whole life ahead of you.
You're going out to play soccer and you punch a guy in the face and he dies and
now you're looking at a murder charge or manslaughter wherever they're going to
charge you.
And then another thing is just some 46 year old guy,
family man going out to a ref a game
and it,
it causes you ended up dead after.
It just,
I dunno,
I dunno why I brought that up.
That really kills the fucking comedy.
Right?
And speak the time to read some advertising.
All right,
here we go.
Oh,
let's get it to the letters for this week.
Um,
to trust or not to trust.
Love is the question.
Hey Bill.
I am a 19 year old guy and had been dating a girl who is almost two years older
than me for about two months and known her for about seven months.
All right.
Do you realize how many numbers are in that?
Let's just start over again.
I'm 19 dating a girl who's 21 for two months and I've known her for seven
months.
Okay,
I got it.
We're in a long distance relationship.
Oh,
Gigi Age and I've never met a come on,
but we Skype almost every day
to trust or not to trust I not to trust sir.
You might as well be up in a space ship.
Her Pussy is on the other side of an ocean.
Do
all right.
You want,
you're going to have to have incredible bone structure and verbal skills to keep
that warm,
satisfied.
I can tell you that if you're going to try and do this over Skype.
All right,
but I plow forward here.
I live in the UK and she's in America.
Uh,
I love her to bits and she says that she loves me.
I had an issue before meeting her and it really felt like I was exercising
demons when I told her about my issues.
She's my first girlfriend plus I've had issues around women previously as well
as bullying in school and we got everything out in the open.
All right.
It felt like it,
it's set in Jesus.
Some weeks I suck at reading and some weeks I really suck at reading me regroup
here.
He said it felt like it had set in stone a relationship that was secure and
trustworthy given we'd shared a lot of our past such as her getting sexually
abused as a child as well as her previous relationship breakdown.
Oh,
breaking down.
Um,
during these two months I have felt myself gaining self esteem.
I never really had as a child.
But yeah,
there always seems to be a,
but with the emails that you get a,
she recently told me she cheated on me with somebody she met in the five months
between meeting or meeting her and starting to date [inaudible] cert.
You haven't been dating,
you've been skyping.
Um,
she tells me it all happened too quick and she felt pressured into it.
I am unsure how to move forward and if have a future to get it along.
Just the relationship is based on trust,
can't they?
Can that be repaired?
Thanks bill.
You should do a show in England against soon.
Uh,
no sir though.
No,
this is beyond over.
You're sifting through ashes of basically a relationship,
a physical one that never existed and the more you Skype or third the lungs,
the heart it's going to be for you to move on.
All right.
You said that you got some self esteem.
I need you to ramp up your self esteem even more and have the self esteem does.
Just say listen and do it in a nice way to say.
Um,
I think you're a great person and I think if you were here,
things would be different,
but you're not.
So,
um,
I think it'd be better for both of us.
Not fucked better for both of us,
cause then that could then she'll be like,
but I'm okay with it.
You gotta always got to stick with you when you're talking about getting out of
relationship.
All right.
Yeah,
I mean,
silver,
you cheated on me.
It's already hard enough that we're on different sides of size of an ocean and
all we can do with Skype,
you know,
at the end of the day,
just be like,
I'm not even mad at you that you cheated on me.
I understand it.
You know,
human beings,
we need a human connection.
And this is like,
I'm fucking a ground control to major Tom.
Like I'm fucking orbiting the earth here.
We can't,
we can't have a,
a,
we can't have a relationship here.
All right.
Okay.
Having said that,
let me see a good just one time,
put them up against the screen.
Kateline you filthy whore.
Sorry.
Um,
yeah,
I would not trust her,
sir.
And I would,
uh,
I might even go into therapy if I was,
you.
Sounds like you had a rough go of it with the bullying and that type of thing to
the point that,
uh,
you're so pulled back that you're having relationships,
a nonphysical one,
um,
over the Internet.
You gotta get out there,
sir.
He got to get out,
you know,
join a fucking volleyball league,
Softball League,
a book of the Club,
the club,
book of the month,
League,
book,
Club of the month.
Whatever the fuck I'm trying to say.
Uh,
you're not into sports.
Take it fucking cooking class.
Just get out there.
Get out there where the broads are at.
You know what?
It's even greater if you're just,
hey,
let's go.
You know?
Oh,
you're into reading,
you're into cooking.
It breaks the fucking ice.
I would do that.
All right.
That's what I would do.
I would not trust to sir.
All right.
You deserve more than that.
Good luck.
And God bless the United States of England.
Um,
is this a trap?
Oh,
Billy boy.
Danny boy,
the lights,
the lights are calling you.
I love the podcast.
Or being,
give me some perspective on this issue.
I am in my early thirties,
and I've been married for five years.
My wife and I recently have been having a sexual that our relationship after a
big low caused by the birth of our two kids and me putting on some extra weight
and that's very honest.
Uh,
we are back to fucking as much or more than we did when we first started dating.
You know,
that was coming off like really like,
uh,
you were mature man and then you went right down to my level.
I don't have to the birth of our two kids.
There's been a sexual resurgent and uh,
you know,
I'd put on some extra weight,
but uh,
dropped a few pounds and we're back down [inaudible] as much as we used.
Um,
here's a tip for married men.
If you want more sex out of your wife,
get your ass to the gym.
It worked for me.
There you go.
Here's a guy practicing what I've preached for the six fucking years that I've
been doing this podcast.
By the way.
Next month is the six year anniversary of me starting this podcast.
Okay.
So I am expecting some,
um,
I don't know what some sort of congratulations I should have done yet.
Last year when it was the five year anniversary.
Um,
so this is going to the gym.
That's right.
He's getting a pex going.
He's fighting off the man tits.
You know,
he's,
he's fucking knocked Kevin that big a former fucking now rockstar God damn gut.
You've got to get rid of that shit and you'll live longer.
I read something one time or overheard in a bar knowing,
knowing me that every extra pound of fat that you have is,
is,
is five miles of capillaries that your heart has to pump blood through.
Just saying extra five pounds,
25 more miles of capillaries.
So you can imagine if you're 30 pounds overweight,
holy fucking shit,
that's a hundred.
If that's a fucking road trip,
150 miles,
you got to get it off.
Um,
that's why you always see little old ladies and little old men.
You don't see jolly old fat 90 year old guys.
You don't,
they're gone.
You know other than Bill Russell,
do you ever seen like a fucking 70 year old seven photo?
There's a reason for that.
Your heart has to fucking pump all the way down to the tippy toes.
Okay.
Also,
my wife has been open and willing to do any manner,
manner of deprived sexual shit that I can think of.
Jesus,
dude,
he goes,
I am living the dream.
I feel like I won the wife lottery.
Well,
I would say you do.
If she's a great mother to that's phenomenal.
So he goes say,
here's the issue.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to guess that she wants to bring somebody else into the bedroom.
I'm going to guess that you fucking open Pandora's box.
And
the way this is red,
if it's another woman,
you don't give a shit.
I'm guessing she wants another dude.
That's what I'm guessing.
She wants a little rotisserie reaction there.
Little Boston market.
Um,
here we go.
See,
here's the issue.
Um,
she has recently been saying that she thinks it would be really hot if I fucked
another woman in front of her.
Oh.
That went on an entirely different direction.
Okay.
She is clear that she doesn't want a threesome.
She doesn't want to participate.
She just wants to be there.
Apparently this is a fairly common fetish known as being
okay.
Uh,
cut queen.
Did you spell it right?
See you see K Queen,
uh,
cut queen.
All right people,
this is the first word I've learned the definition too since,
uh,
what does it buggering of being above a getting buggered anyways,
he says,
now I'm a guy.
No,
I'm a guy.
So obviously I'm into variety and the idea is intriguing and like I said,
she's willing to do basically anything I want to do in the bedroom.
So it seems only fair that I would do what I can to fulfill her sexual
fantasies.
Still.
This seems like a bad idea to me.
Exactly.
Great instincts,
sir.
I don't know what her reaction is going to be.
I don't want to jeopardize my marriage for something like this.
What do you think,
Bill?
Should I just go for it or listen to the voice in my head that says this is a
bad idea if I go for it?
How would you suggest actually finding women,
a woman who was open to the idea of being fucked in front of my wife?
Thanks.
All right,
here we go.
Yeah
Sir.
You're 100% right.
You can't fucking do this.
And,
and all the married guys out there who would like to know,
what are you out your fucking mind.
I do that in a fucking second.
Focus check.
And I know this chicken deal office,
not only she fucking bang mean Farlow fucking office,
okay?
Hey,
love of my life.
Look at me.
Oh me,
I'm fucking baggage,
right?
All of those skies,
those mouth breathing morons.
You know who piss on the side of the road when there's a Wendy's what?
The fucking public bathroom right there.
All of those guys don't listen to them.
So you're 100% right.
Some shit should just remain a fantasy,
okay?
Um,
your parents,
okay?
You have kids,
okay.
And when that happens,
there's a certain level of maturity that you have to fucking have,
okay?
You can't be walking around in the Goddamn gimp outfit when at any second your
fucking kids can open the fucking door to your bedroom.
You know what I'm saying?
And it's just going to be,
uh,
and you're also introducing the chance of you catching a fucking venereal
disease.
Okay?
Because first of all,
any woman that's going to allow you to do that is going to be a frequent,
some level and evidently wearing a condom.
You could still get herpes.
I don't know how it fucking parrot troops down on your ball bag.
I have no idea.
But evidently you can.
All right.
And I gotta tell you some fucking thing.
Some doors should just remain closed.
Um,
okay.
I don't know how I would try to make up in that area.
Okay.
I was gonna say,
if she wanted to fuck another dude,
then you could just act like you were another dude and say a bunch of different
dudes,
shit to her.
Why you had a bent over and she's not looking at you said she could feel,
you know,
you don't,
maybe we're a different cologne,
but this whole,
uh,
you know,
why don't you just get a blowup doll and fuck that in front of her,
Huh?
Dad?
That sounded the fucking like that shit.
Yeah.
Hey,
good.
You
right?
Maybe you could do that.
I don't know what to tell you dude.
But I'll tell you right now,
your instinct to not do it is 100% correct.
All right?
You did hit the lottery with this woman and this is another deal,
dude.
You could be gradually opening this shit up.
You know,
women are phenomenal masters of manipulation,
okay?
This might be her round about way of saying,
I want to fuck another guy.
Okay?
And what she's going to do is get you dirty first,
right?
Just like politics.
We can't have this guy get into the oval office unless we got something on him.
She's doing,
she might be doing that same thing.
Now this is just conspiracy theory.
Don't look sideways at your wife.
Is your eating a bowl of fucking corn checks.
I'm just throwing this shit out here.
All right.
This might be her round about way of fucking getting her to be able to have a
fucking,
all right,
you get to fuck one.
All right.
And not only does she gotta Fuck gonna Fuck Him.
You got to sit there and watch it.
You know,
don't do it.
Do not introduce other fucking people into your relationship.
All right?
Your relationship when it comes to sex and if it's going to fucking work has to
be a secret society as far as my fucking skills go,
my skillset,
get out.
I show up to the gym.
People know what I mean?
Dope.
I got one mid range jumper.
That's all I'm taking.
Everybody knows if he can stop it,
you can stop it.
That's what the fuck I'm coming with.
All right.
I don't even know how the fuck I wanted to.
That analogy.
That was supposed to be making fun of me in the fucking bedroom.
I have my little bag of tricks,
so all I got.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now here,
now I need something because I've never done shit like that.
I never went into that area of fucking freak week.
I never did that.
All right.
Um,
then I think if you are in a fucking healthy relationship at some point,
both men,
women do want a variety and at some point it's gonna come up and you are going
to talk about it and be law.
You know,
maybe we went to Vegas,
maybe yes,
but the,
and then in the end,
you know,
usually after you've banged and got that urge out of your system,
you lay there and you just look at each other.
Yeah.
That was the fucking,
we think we can't do that.
It's fucking gross.
We can't do it.
We like it would tote nights.
Like I'm not trying to judge people who do shit like that,
but it would totally it your,
you know,
it is,
it's a house of cards and you're pulling one out way down near the foundation.
It might stay up,
but the whole thing might come down and you got some kids in there.
So let me ask you this.
At the risk of turning this podcast into a complete freak show.
Not Freak show.
Just,
I dunno,
cause I,
I really don't judge people.
What the fuck they do.
Um,
is there anybody out there that is married,
has a couple of kids and uh,
has,
has had this scenario,
you know,
it has your wife been cool with it?
Did you just bring some girl and you fucking banged her?
You know what,
what exactly,
what is the etiquette when you bang another woman in front of your wife,
you know,
she just sitting there watching,
like she's watching a chess match.
Are you allowed to throw some looks like a c that you liked that move this weed
are,
I dunno,
I dunno what the deal is.
I imagine that there's a bunch of rules.
You're not allowed to do it.
Missionary style.
If you come,
you have to look at me.
Don't look at her.
I mean that seems like there's all these like you know what it is,
it's like you're starting a new sport.
It's kind of like MMA when it first started out and you could punch upper,
cut somebody in the balls and gouge the right,
you can do whatever the fuck you wanted.
And then they'd be like,
God,
we need some parameters here.
Dana white came in and said,
hey,
no more fucking upper cuts to the under carriage.
No more eye gouging,
no kicking in the face when the guys on the ground,
no punches to the back of the head.
He made it civilized.
So I imagine that there has to be some sort of,
um,
yeah,
you know,
civility to the fucking another woman in front of your,
in front of your wife.
MMM.
Look who's kitten?
Hope that would be absolutely phenomenal.
But,
uh,
I,
I just,
I just couldn't imagine,
you know,
my woman died afterwards,
afterwards,
and the woman leaves and then I take a shower,
right?
And then we're sitting down,
you know,
eating spaghettio's.
Uh,
like I would so be praying that she,
the conversation
if that she was going like,
yeah,
I thought that was just,
wow.
I thought that was really,
that was really neato.
But the absolute fucking worst is if they would just be complete awkward
silence.
And then all of a sudden she starts tearing up,
right.
And now here you are going,
but you told me to tow it and the fucking kids are sitting there.
I just sit and think,
no,
I know,
but I just sit there.
You're going to enjoy it that much.
You know,
you don't put that fact with me,
the fucking kids sitting there looking like that kitten,
the shining,
you know when he's fucking looking up with that red rum face.
And I'll tell you right now,
that would be a classic fucking won 80.
That could possibly happen because of uh,
the delicacy of women's emotions.
And I don't mean that like they're weaker or whatever.
This more tapped into him or whatever.
And like I said,
this also could be some fucking
okay,
top shelf pimp shit that she's doing what she really wants to go fuck another
guy.
And she knows,
well the male ego,
I can't come at them with this,
you know?
And if her mindset is like,
hey,
it's just sex,
she's trying to get you on the same tape page.
She has to get you fucking,
she's got to get you dirty first.
So,
um,
I don't know,
but like I said,
if there's people out there who've done this shit,
please email me because I'd love to.
I'd love to know.
Um,
give me a quick
scenario of what happened and then give me a long detailed,
it's not the act.
I get it.
The picture has been painted.
I want to know the aftermath.
I want to know afterwards like what the fuck,
how the fuck.
I want to know what was the first topic that was discussed other than the fact
that your wife had an out of body experience of as far as like the whole
intercourse with you,
you know,
and what is she doing?
She's saving this up to think about later or does she literally engaging from
across the fucking room?
You know,
basically doing the sexual version of the guy who goes to the game with his face
painted.
Oh Shit.
Great email by the way,
sir.
Great fucking email.
Look at US Christ.
We're all the way up to 55 fucking minutes here.
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's shower off with some more,
some more advertising here.
Actually,
I think I got all of them this week.
Didn't,
is that,
and I think I have one more at the end of the podcast I have to read.
MMM.
Let me make sure,
because I get in trouble each week.
It didn't read zippy.net.
That a fuck did you miss that?
What do we got here?
Oh,
that's right.
That's right.
See this,
I checked,
I did my fucking homework.
Um,
we do have another read if I can find it where,
Oh,
where is that other damn read legal zoom.com everyone.
You know what?
You love it.
Look,
you have,
you got to plan for your future.
Don't be that person living day to day.
You want to be that person.
You know,
you're out on the golf course when you're retired and young people look at it,
you go see that guy over there,
that guy did it right.
You know,
and when you tell the story and you're all old and you know,
but still happy,
and the young kid goes,
hey mister,
how did you end up on the golf course?
You can be,
oh,
it goes from dark car 2013 and this is the deal.
You do financial planning,
you get insurance.
But to get real peace of mind,
you have to make sure your family is legally protected.
So where do you turn to get affordable legal protection?
You can trust.
Why legal?
zoom.com everybody for over 12 years they've been helping Americans get
personalized wills,
powers of attorney,
living trusts,
real estate documents,
and more legal zoom.com legal zoom also helped start and maintain businesses
with incorporations in LLC filings,
trademarks and copyrights.
See,
this is the first step you take to start your business.
Legal zoom.com and then when you need the yield outgoing messages,
you go to [inaudible] dot com you get it.
Beautiful.
Um,
time.
Timesaving service was developed by a team of experienced attorneys and legal
zoom takes care of you from start to finish.
Legal Zoom documents have been accepted by courts and government agencies and
all 50 states.
So no matter where you live in the continental United States,
even if you're up in Alaska,
even if you're out there in Hawaii,
living the life,
becoming the next Bruno Mars,
they got your covered.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you to an attorney and provide self help services at your
specific directions for even more savings and to Ber B u r r in the referral box
at checkout.
Um,
if you're a parent or an entrepreneur,
don't wait any longer.
Call or visit legal zoom.com and protect what's yours.
And I hope you guys do it cause I want all you guys to get out there and work
for yourselves if that's what your dream is.
All right,
do you want to work for somebody else?
That's also cool.
I don't judge.
You want to bang another woman in front of your wife because that's what she's
into wealth.
God bless you.
Put on a fucking g gators pitches where Jimmy's put on a Jimmy and have a good
fucking time.
All right,
now where the hell am,
why is my voice cracking?
Was I screaming yesterday when I was drunk?
I thought I was all right.
Okay.
What are we on to the next one here?
Uh,
okay.
Why not?
Well,
you know what,
I didn't answer his last one.
He says,
if I go for it,
how would you suggest actually finding women who is open to the idea of being
fucked in front of my wife?
Yeah.
I mean,
you're gonna,
you're gonna have to find somebody who's a,
I would,
I would try and find somebody who was really advanced in their career,
you know,
like a lawyer.
Do they have to have a certain level of job?
I wouldn't go on fucking craigslist and signed,
find somebody who works at a basket robins who's down for doing something like
that,
you know what I mean?
You're trying to go out and find the cleanest person you can.
And uh,
I would just lay it out on the table,
put it on a table,
and I'd have everybody get fucking tested and then I'd still wear a condom.
And then I'd have at it.
And then,
you know,
as far as the spaghettio conversation afterwards,
that's on you.
All right,
here we go.
Here's the next one.
A lot of sex ones this week.
Want to bang friend's sister a dear Billy fat again?
Uh,
first I would like to say I'm a huge fan,
but that buddy buddy,
but a Purdue,
the podcast is influenced me changing my life for the better.
Great.
He said,
I'm getting over an ex following.
Um,
I dunno.
He's trying to write in the Boston accent and I can't even read that.
Getting over an ex,
following my hat.
And there we go.
Um,
I want to bang my friend's sister.
He even writes this in here for me.
Oh Gee.
G H A backstory.
He's been one of my better friends for about eight years.
And isn't this amazing?
The power of women?
He's been one of my better,
better friends.
He didn't say best friend a wow for eight years.
How old is this girl?
She's 21.
But this is getting creepy.
Let's do the math.
So when he first started being friends with this guy,
his sister was 13 years old.
Dude.
Come on.
Okay,
that's fucking creepy.
So at what point did you start looking at her like,
Hey,
those titties is starting to come in there.
Ah,
Jesus,
ah,
I'm going to have to shower after this one.
But you know what,
I understand,
I understand what happens.
Uh,
for the better part of eight years.
And we went to high school and college together,
party got in trouble and all that other guy stuff and straight,
he's going to put it right on the table.
He goes,
I want to bang her sister.
I'm going to bang his sister.
He goes,
I have known her since she was young and I am now 25 and she's 21.
Okay.
So when she was 13,
you were 17.
Alright.
And she's now a 21 year old lady.
Uh Oh,
this is filthy,
sir.
This is filthy.
Did she still have braces
the first time he saw anyways,
smoking hot.
She's developed.
She was Welker in the Patriots' offense.
This is a creep.
Oh,
this guy is a creep.
I love you.
I love you to death,
sir.
He goes,
I ended up getting a number from the one time we hung out with their brother and
several others.
So you hanging out with his brother and on this side you're suddenly hitting on
her,
dude,
you don't need me.
Listen,
you're going to bang this girl.
You're the,
the end of this email should be you just asking should I do it or should I not?
But as far as anything else,
if you're getting the fucking number
of one of your better friends,
sister,
while he's two feet away,
you know,
waiting for is,
maybe it's his chance to shoot pool,
you know,
you go shoot some stick and you can get the number during that time.
You don't need my help in that department obviously.
All right.
So anyways,
the one time we hung out.
Okay.
And with several others and she used my phone to take pictures and texted
herself the pictures.
Oh yeah.
Oh Jesus.
This is a layup right here.
Okay.
He goes,
I have not contacted her since because I'm not sure what to do.
Should I bank?
My friend's sister,
p s this friend has previously banged one of my other friends,
sisters and has never told them,
oh,
the two wrongs make a right for me to bang my friend's sister.
He wrote it in capital letters.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
All right.
Um,
okay.
Wow.
There's a lot of it.
This is a little fucking twist there in the end.
So you're going to use your fucking Dick is some sort of karmic
like
balance in the sexual universe.
Karmically,
he does deserve this,
but not by you.
The fucking dude whose sister got banked,
he should go and fucking bang his sister and his,
another thing too,
if this girl is as hot as you say she is,
you are running the risk that she's just a fucking narcissistic like Dick Tease
and she's taking phones with your camp.
You have to your cell phone camera just because that's just what she fucking
does is takes all my God,
look how hot I am ad look at this angle.
Look at me doing this.
Oh,
well making the duck face right.
Um,
okay.
Oh Man.
Okay.
I don't know what to tell you here sir.
He could do the age old,
rub one out,
rub one out and then in the Zen afterwards,
think about it.
If you still want to do it then a,
I'd say check your shoot and fucking jump out the back of the plane.
Um,
you know what dude,
this is on you cause I don't,
you said you haven't said much about the guy.
You seem to have sort of like,
this is a guy that you've,
you've hung with,
but you don't seem to be saying that you guys have a real strong friendship and
he's kind of a dirt bag and bag one of your friends.
You know what fucker?
Do it.
Do it
every once in a while.
I say go and do the dumb thing.
You're young enough,
by all means wear a fucking condom.
Uh,
this is going to be so fucking sneaky.
This is another thing too.
I fall you want to do is bang her.
If you have no feelings for you are,
you are risking this fucking relationship
and is,
you know what it's going to be hilarious is when he comes running up to your
house and you know what's going to be raining out because whenever you find out
your friend fucked your sister and you have to go beat the shit out of him,
it's always raining out.
God helps you out.
So your,
your buddy who fucked your sister also doesn't see the tears in your eyes
because it's pouring down raining and you bang on that screen door,
right?
Bang on that fucking thing.
He can,
you know my center front lawn or you guys roll around in the mud punching each
other.
Then you've got to understand that like what is your out going to be there?
Okay,
yeah,
will you fuck so and so sister?
So it's even,
does he know that you know that he fucked to the other person's sister?
This is like an episode of Dallas.
I say,
well let me know.
Look,
this is the last question I have.
That kid you've known for eight years,
what is his martial art background?
What if his,
uh,
when he gets into fights in bars,
does he have a tendency to bite somebody's ear off?
Is he a maniac?
Can you beat this guy if he jumps you when your own driveway?
You know,
you know what?
I don't know why.
Cause I usually give good advice.
I'm telling you right now,
this is a dumb thing to do,
but I'm telling you to go out and go do it.
Go on and go do it.
Fuck him.
He banged your father,
Buddy's sister.
Go ahead.
Make it all right with your Dick.
Make the world right again with you.
Dick.
Please give me a followup email.
I want to know how it goes down.
All right?
But this is the thing.
You got to let her jump in the boat.
All right.
Make it be her fucking idea.
This is the deal the whole time you're doing spec.
You know,
I don't know about this,
but blah,
blah blah.
You know,
I feel guilty cause again,
it died at that and just let it be.
No,
it's okay.
Let her fucking dive bomb down in your deck and then your are right.
Right.
I'm going to tell you all of that advice came with a giant fucking Asterik.
Beyond that,
I'm a moron and I'm not a therapist,
but I'm,
I'm telling you to step into the quicksand cause I think that you have the
ability to make it to the other side.
I believe in you,
sir.
Good luck.
And God bless.
Um,
dilemma.
What would you do for $1 billion that you wouldn't do for a million?
Yeah.
Um,
not a lot.
I'm not motivated by money to be honest with you.
What would I do for $1 billion that I wouldn't do for a million?
All right.
For $1 million.
Now,
you know what I gotta to be honest,
if I wouldn't do it for a million that I wouldn't do it for a billion.
I could live off a million.
Is that tax free by the way?
Free and clear
prenup and all that shit.
That's my million.
Okay.
Let's see.
What would I do for $1 million?
What I eat dog shit.
No,
I wouldn't humiliate myself.
You know,
I,
I'm not motivated,
motivated by money.
You know what,
if I was still working in a warehouse unloading trucks,
that would be a good time to ask me that question.
All right.
But I make enough money to pay my mortgage and get these banker cuts,
cuts off my back as soon as I can.
Uh,
you know what?
I'm a happy guy.
Keep the money.
You can't buy this redheaded con.
I'm sorry.
I know that you wanted a funnier answer than that,
but I don't have it.
I don't give a shit
one site once.
It's not worth the trouble.
I've never understood those game shows that one Rogan hosted what people were
eating Yak balls.
It's like for what?
Why?
Why,
you know,
have a shred of fucking self esteem.
What's wrong with you?
You never do something for the money,
you know,
unless I look,
I'll do a bad standup gig for the money cause I'm trying to pay down the house.
I'll do that.
I mean I would do that,
but nobody's going to give you $1 million to do standup.
Yeah.
Jesus.
We were doing so well.
Let me see if I can make this one funny.
Girlfriends past a Billy boy.
I am.
I have,
I'm having problems.
I'm having problems reading this,
sir.
I'm having problems dealing with all the guys.
My girlfriend has fucked before me.
She's 17 and a senior in high school and she's been with four to five guys
all the way and blown more.
No.
Why are you saying four to five?
You know,
if you've only fucked four or five people,
she got to be able to remember all of them.
She'd Ma,
she said,
my first girlfriend,
I'm 18 BZ there buddy,
go easy.
Is 17 considered under age cause you get busted for statutory rape?
Uh,
make sure she's legal.
He goes,
she's my first gate girlfriend.
I'm 18 but I wasn't a virgin because before,
because my neighbor forced me to have sex with her when I was five.
What
sexual with what?
You're a little Ding Dong.
What was she doing?
Dude,
that's fucking creepy.
I didn't even know that.
Anyways,
she lost her virginity in a one night stand when she was 14.
It just kills me every day that my virginity was stolen from me and she just
gives hers away.
It doesn't help that she still goes to the same school as the guy.
And while they don't really talk,
she fucked him again last summer,
a couple of months before we started dating.
I feel like she's just let people use her and it really disgusts me.
I don't even know if I love her or if I even like her very much.
Am I overreacting about our past or not?
No,
dude,
what you're doing is you're tapping into how you feel about this girl and what
you're looking for in a woman.
And this girl,
isn't it?
Okay?
It's,
you know,
hopefully whatever happened to you didn't happen to her,
but um,
you would,
would,
you do,
sir?
Is you're fighting yourself esteem or discovering it.
All right?
Listen to that voice.
Okay?
This isn't the kind of woman that you are looking to be with.
So I would break up with her.
All right?
And then get with a girl that hasn't fucked four to five guys that you're going
to pass on your way to math class,
all right?
As the deal,
You sound like you've gone through some shit.
I probably go to therapy or without one there.
You know,
whatever the fuck happened to you and uh,
but what's great is you've come out of this that you,
you will,
they're still tapped in what you looking for in a girlfriend you want,
you want,
you know,
a great girl deserves a great guy and you sound like you're a great guy.
So go out there and get a great girl.
That's what you should do.
All right?
And be healthy human beings with one another.
Okay?
Don't let what the fuck happened to you when you're five.
Go down some dark sexual road that you pick these damaged girls that you relate
to faulty.
You probably need to go to therapy,
work some shit out,
all right?
But she didn't write me.
You did.
So I'm telling you to do that.
And um,
yeah,
get yourself a myth to fuck is with my voice.
Get a girl.
You're proud to be with that.
You want to bring home to your parents.
All right.
That's the one.
There you go.
All right.
And that's it.
Everybody.
That's the podcast for this week.
I just got a couple of things.
I got some announcements as far is where I'm going to be a,
this is actually a huge gig in my life.
Um,
I've always wanted to work Las Vegas and I did it on the way up,
but the way Vegas works is either a,
you know,
yeah.
Headlining a great rump or your work in some dump.
And I was always in some dump and it was a depressing place to be because when
you work in a dump in Las,
you know,
basically the,
uh,
you know,
you just see these gamblers that fucking,
they don't have any money and it's just,
it's,
it's fucking horrific.
So I was never able to headline anyplace.
Nice.
One hours out there,
except when I toured with,
uh,
Jimmy Norton,
Jim Breuer,
and uh,
David tells,
so this is the first time I'm actually going to go get to go out there and
headline a major casino.
I'm going to be at the Mirage casino May 17th and May 18th in Las Vegas,
Nevada.
I'm obviously beyond honored to be out there and um,
I love it if you guys came out,
showed up,
took a trip to Vegas or whatever,
I believe there's still a few tickets left and um,
and later on in the month I'm going to do a nice east coast run count Basie
theater in Red Bank,
New Jersey.
May 29th,
May 30th.
I'm going to be at the hope I say this right.
Mayor Hoff Symphony Hall in Baltimore,
Maryland.
May 31st the State Theater Center for the arts in Easton,
Pennsylvania.
And on June 1st I have two shows at the Borgata casino and spa in Atlantic City,
New Jersey.
So,
uh,
please come out there.
I believe on that trip that New Jersey swing is going to be the one and only the
teen idols sensation Joe to Rosa who has a half hour comedy central special
debuting I believe this weekend on comedy central.
Please email or tweet Joe to Rosa Facebook and find out when his half hour
specialist please watch is special cause how comedy central works is,
is if the ratings are beyond a certain point,
they're going to keep showing it.
And uh,
Joe's one of the great guys both on and off business who would be really great
if you guys would,
uh,
if you check out his special.
And with that we are down to the final announcement that I have on this.
If you guys would like to donate to the podcast,
go to Amazon,
go to bill bird.com on the uh,
uh,
click on the podcast page.
And if you want to buy something on Amazon,
click on the Amazon banner and a,
and then just go buy something.
And they kicked me.
You don't,
it doesn't cost you any more money.
They just kicked me a fee.
And then I take a portion of that fee.
I sent it to the wounded warriors project and everybody wins.
And um,
oh also the hard copy version of my standup special,
uh,
you people are all the same is available at [inaudible] dot com and also the
downloadable one for all you youngsters out there and a,
and this is it.
Personal capital.
Outro read.
Here we go.
My first outro read right here.
Um,
now that the podcast is over,
everybody go sign up for your free of,
let me do that again cause we have to send these audio recordings to them.
All right,
here we go.
Now that the show is over,
go sign up for your free account with personal capital so you can all your
assets on one screen.
Pay Less than broker fees and make all your investments grow faster.
Go to the podcast page on bill bird.com and click the personal capital banner
banner's sorry that the podcast.
That's the podcast page on bill bird.com to click the personal capital banner
and set up your free account today.
Please do it.
I want to help you guys save some money.
Invest your money,
right?
I want to help you guys when you're in your old age.
You know,
have your money instead of the bankers.
Right.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless Ya.
Don't take any shit and I'll see you next week.